this morning on the dish the sweet story
of serbia sani an immigrant from india
she recently turned her confection
company into tag mo a new york
restaurant celebrating both her heritage
and other women of color working in the
food world and next week she'll be
honored at the icona class dinner at the
prestigious james beard house honoring
diverse voices from throughout the globe
making significant contributions to
culture i recently got a taste of chef
sani's philosophy and her many skills in
the kitchen
we start at the end mitai is indian
confections dishing about desserts and
the finely crafted masterpieces pastry
chef turned restauranteur serbi sani
tastes like peanut butter right
what is chickpea flour wow it has a
little smoky consistency some of these
sweets are made with condensed milk
others with lentil or nut flour and a
lot of these are have been like part of
my childhood and every one of those
suites that we have in our boxes has a
story to tell bite-sized memories and
other delights featured at tag mo the
restaurant sunny opened during the
pandemic
all inspired by her homeland india and
the father whose footsteps she hoped to
follow my dad is an artist
and i wanted to be an artist i didn't
get into an art school i got into hotel
management and my dad was like well you
can always be a chef he's like food is
in heart and then this was the year 1992
it was unheard of when i started working
in 95 in hotels in india there were
maybe a total of 10 women chefs
in the entire deli like i was one of the
few women
that were
making a career in the kitchen not many
dads back then pushed their daughters
into the male-dominated culinary
industry but hers was special and so was
her timing my first job was at the
sheraton hotel in new delhi
and they were opening an all-women's
kitchen at that time really yeah
why
um i don't know the chef had that idea
an idea that became sani's dream
reimagined when she came here to study
food and anthropology at nyu
it makes me feel like as if i'm in india
of course because there's so many indian
faces around here yeah but also like
it's very global right she's settled
into jackson heights queens an enclave
for south asian immigrants my gosh i can
go get a sorry
yes
go shopping and began working her way
through new york's indian dining scene
including at the michelin star devi i
love the chicken sauces
she comes back to queens regularly to
eat look at how there's like a little
bite of everything in there
and grocery shop at patel brothers so if
you want
essence of india you come to a store
like this you definitely should
a slice of home that helps source her
restaurant what is this is this chickpea
flour what is ghee
basically clarified butter it doesn't
have any
sort of additives in some ways it's pure
fat but it's actually good for you okay
that's what they tell you that's what
this is take your word for it every nut
and every seed you can imagine it's here
it's pretty amazing right
punjabi mix oh that's like a mouth
cleanser
okay i'm gonna get this
it's sonny's bi-monthly routine going
between her old digs in lower
manhattan's south street seaport home to
her restaurant named for the bhutanese
word for tigress
sani is a proud queer chef creating
opportunity in space just like her very
first experience in that all women's
kitchen in new delhi nearly three
decades ago i also wanted to bring that
sensibility of eating on the table
just kind of have a conversation of who
are the homemakers what's the real
recipes how have we been eating as
indians and how is that like evolving
through the centuries and where are we
today her dishes are a culinary tour
through the diverse regions of india
home to more than 1.3 billion people i
grew up in the north and so for me to
like
make south indian spices or being all
these spices was certainly new and i
practiced and owned my skill in the last
few years and i've brought this all to
the table here today
like caramel chata this is sort of my
own creation
um and it is um
mangoes some jicama
uh chickpeas uh that is tossed in a
devil's chutney as well you're not
having it i'm gonna have something yes
yes you must eat with me
chat means by the way to lick and like
anything that is on the street yes
anything that's on the street and you're
like licking your fingers is chart and
then we have what we call as sabudana
vara which is a bombay
street food and that is of course paneer
oh this is my favorite and bread roll
stuffed with paneer green chilies and
onions with a tomato chili sauce this
was our breakfast so many times this is
breakfast
we go from breakfast
back to that classic indian dessert okay
so tell me which one you think i'm going
to like the best point it pointed i'm
not looking
so i'm going to try each one
starting with chocolate burfi
caramel burfi and a few others including
this one a kaju cutlet made with cashew
nuts which one was your favorite
see
i said
oh my gosh i love it this is so
delicious
and i brought some for everybody
and they're special they are giving
honor to pride
they're rainbow confections beautiful
yes we do we'll be right back
for those of you still still with us
we're talking about tag mo and yeah i
just have to say you know sitting there
having a conversation with serbi in her
restaurant and watching people go in
uh we're talking her workers it was
really a treat because she is is all
about employing not just women
uh she employs men as well but but
everyone across the spectrum she is a
proud queer woman who believes that you
know there are those who are
discriminated against in the food
industry and
many of them not just women but but
folks who uh happen to be of a different
persuasion when it comes to lgbtq trans
everybody walks through her doors that's
amazing yeah it really is that food but
i wasn't kidding can we please road trip
there not that this doesn't look good
but food itself can we try so we have so
i have in front of me i have kaju kotli
yes
oh is it
keep going
okay did i get that right right and
caramel burfi there it is
was the caramel the one that you like
the most or the chocolate well i you can
read it and eat it as well our producer
is speaking yeah the chocolate perfect i
i i will eat it but i have talked
cane sugar white chocolate wow not too
sweet it's not too sweet and it's a bite
of deliciousness and silverleaf